there's God bond has always been
important to mine would because not only
is it a wonderful Association to have
every two years they look forward to a
bond from coming in it guaranteed the
future of the studio through the lean
times you know when there wasn't much
else going on and so a bond come coming
in spending multi-million dollars taking
over you know half the stage in the
studio was always a big event
Pinewood was actually formed by J Arthur
rank and Charles boot Charles boot being
a builder J Arthur rank being a
Methodist he wanted to spread the word
the good Word of God he wanted to make
wholesome family films here at Pinewood
you got the film factory but over the
back fence is black park and you've got
something like 100 acres of parkland and
Lake the name was derived through the
the pine trees in the gardens here so
the first syllable was from the pine
trees on wood from Hollywood which J
Arthur ant was keen to emulate you've
had big franchise here like the Superman
films were made here the Batman films
originally were made here and the carry
on movies the bonds you know they keep
coming and so there was an indigenous
industry but there was also always the
big renters coming in to hire space and
to move the big productions and I think
in the film industry in Britain in
particular there's always feast and
famine who in the 70s and 80s Margaret
Thatcher's government in particular
their attitude was what businesses
should stand on their own two feet there
was no financial carrot and so country
like Ireland for instance introduced a
tax incentive and everybody went to
Ireland Mel Gibson decamped with
Braveheart because he was going to shoot
in Scotland couldn't get any cooperation
couldn't get any subsidies Ireland said
please come over here use our army and
we'll give you 20 percent tax credit so
off we went to Ireland pinewoods
actually approaching its 80th
anniversary and the competitiveness is
sort of cranked up a little bit because
there's a wonderful producers tax credit
in the UK which qualifying films can
actually claw back up to 25% of their UK
spend big American Pictures is now
coming into this country like Star Wars
for instance just been shooting here for
virtually 18 months
Cinderella shall not go to the ball the
Marvel Avengers films have been shot
hopefully that will continue Disney I
now have a long-term arrangement with
Pinewood for the next eight years I
believe where they're renting something
like ten sound stages for their
production so they're making the
commitment to working in the UK it's a
studio that's geared for the future they
look towards the future all the time
with half an eye on the past and the
great value that they've always given
productions they look forward to what
they can do in the future